well there were many candidates for
today's daily cancellation but
ultimately when faced with a surplus of
potential cancel Lees I have to Simply
go with whichever one I find the most
personally annoying and for that we turn
to will frell an actor who as it happens
and I went back and checked hasn't St in
a good comedy since 2008 with Step
Brothers but that's not why he's
canceled today he's canceled for this as
the blaze reports quote act Will Farrell
told a group of mostly women that it's
time for them to take over the world
when he gave opening REM Mar s for the
women and entertainment Galla hosted by
the outlet um The Hollywood Reporter
frell likely earned a spot at the Galla
because he co-owns a production company
focused on female Le television and
movie productions called Gloria Sanchez
Productions founded in 2014 as a
division of his existing production
company frell went on to plead with
actress Carrie Washington to run for
president joking that the gala could
start a GoFundMe page to raise money for
her campaign The Anchor Man actor noted
that Washington would receive the equity
and entertainment award in recognition
for her work quote amplifying the voices
of underrepresented communities in the
entertainment industry and
Beyond now it's hard for me to imagine
an award that could possibly be more
meaningless than the equity and
entertainment award this is an award
that would win the award for most
meaningless award which somehow would be
a more meaningful award than the equity
and entertainment award itself but also
just for the record it is of course a
total misnomer that black people are
underrepresented in the uh entertainment
industry in fact according to the
jobsite ziacom 133% of professional
actors are black which is precisely in
line with the overall black population
in the United States so far from being
underrepresented they are exactly
specifically correctly represented
that's not really the point yeah there
was a lot of graveling to quote unquote
people of color going on at the women
and entertainment Gala but most of the
graveling was to women as you might
expect given the name of the gala and on
that end here's will farell forget about
the entertainment world isn't it isn't
it just
time isn't it just time for women to run
the planet I I
mean I'm I'm s I'm not just trying to
Plate you I
swear but I don't know what else to do
because
we men uh we've been running the show
since what 10,000 BC something like that
and we're not doing doing so good
so please can you guys just take
over now I understand this is mostly
just the typical Hollywood girl power
stick I also realize that this is coming
from will Ferell who's not exactly known
for his wisdom or
Insight still it's worth pointing out
that everything he said there which is
the kind of thing you hear all the time
these days is absolute nonsense so let's
start at the end he says that men have
been running things since 10,000 BC and
we quote haven't been doing so good now
it's a bit of a confusing sentence even
leaving aside the poor grammar when he
says we haven't been doing so good does
he mean that things have started to
decline recently or is he saying that we
haven't been doing so good the whole
time now if the former doesn't really
make sense because men have never been
less in charge than they have been in
recent years so if you think things that
have been have been going poorly
recently as women have increasingly
taken charge it's hard to see how even
more women in charge will fix that but
we'll get back to that in a moment on
the other hand if you're saying that men
have been screwing things up the entire
time since 10,000
BC then I guess I need to know how well
you think we should be doing at this
point after all what have men done since
10,000 BC well nothing really I guess
except build
civilization almost every major
advancement and achievement in the
history of mankind since the dawn of
human Society
itself has been made by a man not not
all of
them but but most of them I mean most of
them that you can name have been
achieved by a man that's just a fact you
know I have two dogs now and the magic
power of rough greens is in my home if
Santa needs some real power on his
sleigh this Christmas he can borrow my
two dogs have them as long as he wants
who are stronger than ever since
starting their uh diets their
supplementing their diets with rough
greens naturopathic Dr black the founder
of rough greens is focused on improving
the health of every dog in America
before I started feeding my dog rough
greens I had no idea that dog food is
dead food it contains very little
nutritional value think about it
nutrition isn't Brown it's green let
rough greens bring your dogs food back
to life rough greens is a supplement
that contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog food just sprinkle rough Greens
on their food every day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough greens
it supports healthy joints improves bad
breath boosts energy levels and so much
more we are what we eat and that goes
for dogs too naturopathic Dr Dennis
black is so confident Ruff greens will
improve your dog's health he's offering
my listeners a free jumpstart trial bag
so your dog can try it get a free jump
start trial bag delivered straight
through your door just a few business
days go to Ru greens.com mat or call 844
ru700 that's rfffg greens.com or call
844 Ru 700 today if you're a business
owner and you need to grow your team
your perfect gift is is simple you want
a smart hiring solution and look no
further than zip recruiter right now zip
recruiter is giving it to you for free
at ziprecruiter.com Walsh now you might
be asking how zi recruiter is a gift to
those who are hiring well zi recruiter
uses smart matching technology to
identify the most qualified people for a
wide range of roles zi cter lets top
candidates know when they are a great
match for your job to encourage them to
apply and the bow on top well if you see
a candidate who's a great match for your
job zipper cter makes it easy to send
them a personal invite so they're more
likely to apply get your hiring wrapped
up quickly with zi recuiter four to five
employers who post on zi recuit get a
quality candidate within the first day
so just go to this exclusive web address
right now to try zi recuiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com Walsh again that's
ziprecruiter.com
wsh zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire things haven't been perfect of
course we're talking about the whole
span of civilization's existence it's
not going to be a smooth sailing the
whole time but mostly through mail
leadership we went from mud Huts to uh
walking on the moon in a few thousand
years now I have nothing to compare it
to neither does will frell but like I
think that's pretty impressive that's
not
bad is that not good enough for will
frell is it not fast
enough is there any reason at all to
think that women if they were solely in
charge would have done
better is there any reason to think that
Humanity's prospects in the future will
be improved by getting more women into
leadership positions well we don't
really have to speculate about that you
know Society has run through
institutions and those institutions have
increasingly elevated women to
leadership roles over the past several
decades and on will Farrell's Theory and
on the theory of any feminist or anyone
else who's adopted this line we should
be able to look around and see that
these institutions have measurably and
significantly improved due to the rapid
dramatic rise in female
leadership but do we see that have the
deliberate specific efforts to increase
the proportion of women in leadership
roles actually helped any institution
Thrive can you name a single institution
that has been improved by these efforts
to put more women into positions of
leadership it's a question now I posted
this question on Twitter yesterday and
predictably lots of people are very
upset at me for asking an uncomfortable
question even more predictable lots of
people missed the point entirely and
started naming individual women who were
great leaders like Queen Isabella and
Katherine the Great who both presided
over governments comprised almost
entirely of men by the way but but
that's besides the point I'm not asking
whether there have ever been any great
individual female leaders in the history
of mankind of course there have been I'm
certainly not asking whether there have
ever been any impressive wonderful
competent intelligent women in the world
obviously there have been many of those
I should know I married one of them but
the question is whether any
institution has been quantifiably
improved by the effort to increase as a
percentage the number of women in
leadership
roles perhaps another way of asking this
is this has the deliberate feminization
of any institution helped it
succeed okay can you look at anything
now after years of trying to get women
more involved and into the leadership
ranks and say wow that institution is
doing way better than it was before
if you can give an example then give
it but I don't think you can I don't
think anyone
can I think instead we all recognize
even if we don't want to admit it that
every institution or field that you can
name has become less effective and less
productive and less competent and less
impressive as women have been moved up
the ranks and Leadership has been
Diversified now this is certainly true
of the milit Ary Academia law
enforcement The Sciences medicine even
the film
industry now it's true you know um and
that's true most of all by the way of
the two most important institutions in
society which is the church and the
family the church in this country has
fallen apart as it's been feminized and
the institution of the family has done
the same as Society has insisted that
women should be at the head of
it you know you can't deny that the
family is much more much more female L
today than it ever has been in the
history of the world and you also can't
really deny that the family is weaker
and more unstable than it's ever been in
the history of the
world now correlation does not prove
causation but there's a lot of
correlation here across basically every
institution in the modern
world enough to we might say seriously
call into question the idea that the
world can be fixed by putting women in
charge of
it and certainly enough to say that will
Ferell is today canceled hey YouTube
thanks for listening to the show if
you'd like access to my full show with
no ads you should go to dailywire.com
and use promo code Walsh to get two
months free on all annual plans see you
there